and finally tonight we want to send a  big hug to all of our eight news now  pets on their special day  here's aspen and tootsie roll from our  carolyn williams  and this cutie his name is bama it's  mark zamora's dog  and blue and mishka from our director  rochelle they are beautiful bruno and  bruce from our amazing man these are  going fast  this is buddy davis from leon dakota and  ruger from our editor jason  freckles and samantha from our  photographer henry takai gus and nala  are they are for uh pets my own henry  mocha and hartley  i contina from david weiner janie from  eric jungwood and lacey and tucker from  caitlin they're adorable  reggie is coming up from our very own  kevin martin and  treasure finally from madison kimbrough  our station has a lot of pets i'm out of  breath  happy national love your plant day to  all of them right  shout out to my houseplant